VIC FRYZEL: Welcome to Google
I/O, and thank you for coming
to this talk.
Today, what I'm going to be
doing is introducing a new way
to administer your business on
Google, specifically with
Google Apps.
So just a quick poll.
How many people in the room are
familiar with Google Apps
and the Admin APIs?
Everyone.
OK, you're in the right room.
So the Admin APIs are a set of
APIs that allow you to manage
your Google Apps for Business
domain or other additions, and
do things like create users
and manage your domain's
resources while also making
it easier to perform some
automated tasks.
So this is a collection
of more than 15 APIs.
It includes things today like
the Provisioning API, or the
Group Settings API, or the
Reports API, et cetera.
So the problem with this is that
thousands of applications
use these APIs every
single day.
There's a large number of these
APIs, but the developer
experience of the APIs
can be a little bit
difficult to navigate.
So if you break this down,
actually, this translates into
more than 125 million
requests per day.
That's more than a lot of small
companies get for their
entire app.
So here, these requests coming
in are doing things to manage
Google Apps for Business
domains.
What we're going to talk
about today is
making things even easier.
And if there's one thing that
you leave the room with today,
it should be with an
understanding that you should
go home, sleep, after Google
I/O, and then come into work
the next day and adopt what
we're about to launch, because
we're going to make your lives
significantly easier.
So this is directly
for IT admins.
Or if you're an ISV who's
developing software for users
of Google Apps for Business, if
you're a reseller of Google
Apps for Business, all
of this stuff is
going to apply to you.
So we've, over the years, taken
a lot of requests from
developers.
So the Google Apps Admin APIs
are actually one of our oldest
sets of APIs.
I've worked at Google for almost
four years, and I've
worked on them since my first
day at Google, and then even
before that, they existed.
So we've gotten a lot of
requests from developers over
the years, and today,
we're going to
address some of those.
One of the top requests was the
ability to search and sort
your result sets just much more
easily from things in
your domain.
Another one is batch requests.
I need to, for instance, create
a bunch of users at
once or get a whole bunch of
information about a collection
of users at the same time.
Enterprise attributes.
And then more customizable
reporting.
And then finally, I think the
biggest request has been for
functional parity with the admin
panel for Google Apps
for Business.
So here, we have my
friend Namrata.
This is all of her information
in my test domain.
And you can see there's a whole
bunch of information
here that is pretty common.
This represents Namrata in
a traditional business
environment.
So I have things here like her
phone number, her email
addresses, which groups she
belongs to, and also her
username and profile photo.
So today, there's a problem and
the problem is that to get
her profile photo, I have to
make a call out to the
Profiles API.
And then to get her username and
other user information, I
have to make a call out to
the Provisioning API.
Yet another API call, at least,
to get things like her
nickname or her aliases, and
then yet a fourth request to
get the groups to which
she belongs.
So this is a little
bit too much.
And just a quick show of hands,
how many people in the
room have run into
things like this?
Almost everybody raises
their hands.
OK, so I have good
news for you.
Today, we're launching
the Admin SDK.
And the Admin SDK is a brand
new developer experience
around managing things
in your Google Apps
for Business domain.
What we're going to do is talk
about how we're going to
simplify the developer
experience, and I'm going to
introduce a few new
APIs to you.
And I think what you're going to
love about this is how easy
it is to integrate, and also
how easy it is to do more
advanced things in
your domain.
So we're launching
two APIs today.
The first one is the Directory
API, and the next one is the
Reports API.
I'm going to go through
each one.
The goal of the two APIs is to
be as simple as possible,
giving you all of the data you
need and all of the actions
you need while getting
out of your way.
Consistent, so what we want to
do here is make sure that all
of our API surface areas look
identical so that you don't
have to do special tweaks or
integrations between multiple
APIs in order to get
things working.
And then lastly,
comprehensive.
We want to expose as much of
the functionality in the
Google Apps Admin Panel
as possible.
So when you come away today,
know that these are our goals,
overall, for the platform.
So the Directory API allows
you to manage
objects in your domain.
So this includes the traditional
objects like
users, groups, and org units.
However today, the Directory
API will also allow you to
manage devices in your domain.
So to give you some sense of
what's going on here, here I
have a bunch of common endpoints
that you would use
today for things like the
Provisioning API or the
Profiles API.
And what we're going to do is
boil all of these things down
into a single API called
the Directory API.
And here you can see all of
those endpoints, they
roll up into one.
So this is going towards the
simplicity goal that we have
for the Admin SDK.
The next one is the
Reports API.
So the Reports API is going to
allow you to create just
richer reports on things going
on within your domain.
Here, you can see this graph was
able to be generated with
all of the data coming back,
and this is just usage
activity of each service
within your domain.
Another way to generate a report
is just all of the
different activities going on
within your domain so that you
can, much more easily,
do things
like audits, for instance.
So let's take a demo.
So Ankur in the audience
wrote this demo app.
It's called Device Explorer,
and this is
doing something new.
So a few important points about
this application are
that it's hosted on App Engine,
so it's a third-party
application, and it's using
everything that I just talked
about to allow you to manage
devices within a Google Apps
for Business domain.
Ankur did a few special
things.
One, he allowed his admin to log
in with Google+ Sign In,
which is a new mechanism for
signing users into your
applications, and you can use
that with Google Apps for
Business domains.
So that's definitely something
that you should consider
changing your application
to use.
It's just a lot easier
to implement.
And also, it allows you to get
all of the same access that
you have with your application
today.
The next thing is he used the
Directory API to create a
Device Explorer here.
And this Device Explorer allows
you to manage devices
within your domain.
So here, for example, if I click
on this device, this is
all of the information about
the owner of this device.
And if I go back, if I click on
the device itself, you can
see all of the information
about the device.
So this is important because on
occasion, what will happen
is one of your users may
register a non-approved device
on your domain or somebody
would lose their device--
maybe leave it on a train or
something to that effect.
And what you as the admin have
to do is be able to disable
this device quickly
and easily.
Now, it really gets a lot easier
to do mass changes with
tools like this.
So obviously, in your own
business or in your own
software, you may need to do
some advanced things like
provision 1,000 devices, and
that's not something you want
somebody clicking around
and doing manually.
So that's where the Directory
API really shines.
It allows your application to
do more advanced concepts.
So here, just to take a simple
example, what I can do is
select this device from Ken, and
I can do various things.
Its current status is Approved,
but I can also block
it or delete it.
So if I block it and take this
action, it says Done.
And if I reload the page, you
can see, after the Wi-Fi
cooperates, that the device from
Ken is now blocked, and
this has also been applied in
the Google Apps Admin Panel.
So this is one of
the new features
we're launching today.
And this demo application is one
way to kind of see what's
going on there.
So if I come back to the
presentation, the next thing
we're going to do is walk
through the code that made
that application possible.
So just to give you an idea of
how the code is structured,
it's a very common model
view controller set up.
Here, the servlets act as
controllers, and the view is
index.html.
That's really just a template.
And then we have our servlets
talk to the client library.
Our data model here is
completely represented by the
Directory API.
So that's important to note.
We don't really have
a local data model.
So the first thing we're going
to do is query mobile devices
in the domain.
So here, you can see a method
on the devices servlet to do
that, and you can see actually
how simple it is.
So here, just with four lines
of code, I'm able to get a
list of devices within the
domain and then print them to
the screen.
This is one of the ways that
we're really trying to address
that simplicity factor again.
Just making it easier for you to
get the data that you need
out of your Google
Apps domain.
The next thing we can do is
query for individual devices,
and then just return the list.
So the previous method just
printed a list, and here, we
actually get the list of
devices themselves.
And then we can also get
matching devices with a query.
So I don't know if you noticed
this in the sample
application, but there was
a search mechanism.
And I can apply that search
mechanism here.
In case I have thousands of
devices in my domain, I don't
have to find each
one by scrolling
through hundreds of pages.
That add row to device table
method is really just a view
generator method that creates a
table row with the device's
information.
And then taking action
on a device.
For instance, I blocked
a device.
You can see how that's
done here via
this take action method.
So the take action method is
really just a wrapper around
these five lines of code.
So these five lines of code
create a new directory object,
which allows you to interact
with the Directory API.
And then a mobile device action,
I which create a new
action object that
I want to set.
In this case, it
might be block.
And that action parameter is
just a string representing the
action's name.
And then I set up the request,
and I call Execute.
And once I call Execute, this
makes a request out to the API
and blocks the device.
So one thing that we've noticed
is that an easy way
for us to guarantee that there
is feature parity between the
Google Apps user interface and
the Admin SDK is to use our
own Admin SDK to build the
Google Apps interface.
So what does that mean?
Well, I'm going to switch over
here to my demo tablet.
And this is something
launching towards
the end of the month.
It's a mobile C panel.
So this mobile C panel allows
me to manage my users and
groups and other domain
resources while on the go.
So this works on my phone or
on my tablet, and this is
something that Google
is going to release.
The important thing to note
about this entire application
is it's built using our
Admin SDK, so we're
eating our own dog food.
We know that the Admin SDK works
and works well, because
we have to use it as well.
So here if I click Users,
you can see all of
the users in my domain.
And if I click Ankur, I can
find out more information
about Ankur.
So here, I can do other things,
like I can edit
Ankur's information.
So I could change his name,
I could change his email
address, or change
his phone number.
I could add a new
phone number.
I'll just punch in a random
phone number here, click Done,
and OK, and it updated
the user on the spot.
So what that just did was make
a call out to the Admin SDK
and save that new
phone number.
If I come back, click Done,
I can do other things.
I can also suspend the user
or delete the user.
And then if I come back to this
menu, I can also do other
things like manage groups.
So if I look at the All Managers
@ACME Group, here you
can see this admin@ankurt10sep
is one of the users, but I've
decided that I want to
make this user an
owner of this group.
So I edit the role, and I click
Owner, and I click Save.
And when I click Save, Ankur is
now an owner of this group.
So you can see there, using
this app that we've built,
we're actually using a lot of
the features that you would
have to use in order to build
your own applications with
maybe more advanced use cases.
So this is something that's
becoming super important to us
and it's a goal for us
in the long term.
And I really want to sell that
point because I realize that
previously, there has been
somewhat of a disconnect
between the Google Apps Admin
UI and what was available to
do via the API.
And this is something that
we're really keen on
addressing.
I know that a lot of you in the
audience need to do some
edge case that the UI allows
and the API doesn't.
And so what you have to tell
your users is, oh, by the way,
you can't do that in my tool.
You have to go to the
Apps Admin UI.
We are addressing that
point directly.
So in the coming months, you'll
start to see that get
better and better and better.
So what's next?
The next things that we have
going on are essentially
improving the developer
experience across the board.
So here, in the documentation--
forgive me.
Let me switch my screen.
Pretty noob mistake
right there.
So let me show you the
documentation here.
This is how it looks today, and
you can see that huge list
of APIs I mentioned
previously.
And it's also kind of difficult
to find out what you
need to do in order to address
your use case.
Today, we're launching this,
and it's our new developer
experience for the Admin SDK.
So here you can see, we've moved
to more documenting the
use cases and not so much
documenting individual APIs.
So if you need to manage users,
for instance, or if
you're new to the Admin SDK, you
probably don't really care
that that's the Directory API.
Rather, you just want to see
how to do it and then later
on, you'll start to learn our
own terminology as you become
more and more of an expert.
So we're working on making it
easier for new users of the
Admin SDK while also keep
keeping it as good reference
material for advanced users.
And we're also working on
keeping it very up-to-date
when we add new features
to the Admin SDK.
So in making integration easier,
again, we're working
on reproducing the simplicity
and consistency of the two
APIs, both Directory and
Reporting, into other APIs
that will be a part
of the Admin SDK.
And we're also looking at giving
more feature complete
sample applications in a broad
range of languages.
What's important to note is that
these two new APIs are on
our new API infrastructure
at Google.
You'll know that some of the
previous APIs have been on
this thing called G Data, and
G Data had custom client
libraries for every
single API.
Whereas with the new API
infrastructure, the client
libraries are consistently
kept up-to-date in a more
automated way so that, for
instance, the Java client
library, if you download the
latest version, you will
immediately have access to the
latest features of the API.
There's no delay there.
The other thing, again, that
we're really focusing on is
continued feature parity
with Google UX.
And we're starting to do this by
developing the applications
for Google using our
APIs first and then
adding features second.
So with that, the upcoming
features.
We're going to add more
enterprise objects in the API.
We know this is a huge feature
request, and we're working on
making the availability of
data just much wider.
We're also working on giving
powerful structured search.
The worst thing on the planet
that I'm sure everybody in the
room has encountered is having
to fetch a full list of
resources and then manually
search them
yourself, and that sucks.
So we're working on making that
just a lot better so that
you don't have to do a lot of
that processing on your end.
Also, we're giving an extensible
user schema--
and this is a big one-- so that
you can set more and more
properties on a per user basis
so that you don't have to have
a separate data store for some
properties about your users
and then use Google Apps for
the other properties.
We're going to give you a
login activity audit.
Again, I think this
has been a pretty
popular feature request--
the ability to just detect
logins from users.
And then lastly, we're going to
give G+ reports and let you
find out exactly how
your users are
interacting with Google+.
So with that, thank you.
And what I'd like to do
now is take questions.
There's two microphones.
[APPLAUSE]
AUDIENCE: Hey Vic.
It's Charlie Wood.
A couple of questions.
First of all, I know there was
talk about push notifications
in at least some
of these APIs.
Is that included?
Is it roadmap?
VIC FRYZEL: That's
in the roadmap.
AUDIENCE: Second, what is the
process, or is there a
process, for increasing
API quotas?
VIC FRYZEL: So that's a
very good question.
So these two new APIs are
managed in the Google APIs
Console, which I didn't show.
If you've used any other Google
API really, I'm sure
you're familiar with the
Google APIs Console.
When you go there, there is, as
of today, this new option
called Admin SDK.
And when you can flip Admin SDK
on and off, you can also
request more quota.
And what that does is it sends
an automated item into our
system and then we review
it each week.
And then that would allow
you to get more quota.
AUDIENCE: And then finally, this
is kind of a detail, but
when you're fetching a long
list and you're paging 100
results at a time, did it make
it in to where the total
number of requests and the total
result set is actually
in each page?
VIC FRYZEL: You mean the result
size, like the total
number of users in each page?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah,
that made it in.
AUDIENCE: All right.
Thanks.
VIC FRYZEL: I'll take
one from the back.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
My name's Scott Howell.
I'm curious about the Google
Sign In for external websites
and how this Admin SDK--
can you assign different levels
of rights to those
users for those external sites,
ie, say I have, I don't
know, 500 users in my Google
domain and I want to give them
access to an external website,
can I manage those user levels
through this?
VIC FRYZEL: So you mean access
to use Google+ Sign In on
another website?
AUDIENCE: On an external
website not part of--
VIC FRYZEL: I'm with you.
AUDIENCE: Not a Google App.
VIC FRYZEL: So currently, you
can't manage that per
application basis.
What you can do is
revoke access
after it's been granted.
And what we're working on is
making it so that you can
control individual access.
Let's hypothetically say that
you wanted to add an
application to all of your
users, and you want to give
them access to that application
specifically, but
not to all of the other
applications on the web,
that's something that
we're working on.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Great.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm [INAUDIBLE] from Sears.
The question that I had is when
you are trying to add the
objects, do have the ability to
maintain the history of the
changes that have been done
on the user profiles?
Like for example, my phone
number was XYZ.
Phone number now is ABC.
Can I track the XYZ as well?
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah, so that's part
of this new SDK as well.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Thanks.
VIC FRYZEL: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Is this new API going
to be available, or is
it available already, for
Google Apps Script?
VIC FRYZEL: For Google
Apps Script?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
VIC FRYZEL: So the existing apps
interface exists already
on Apps Script, and what we're
working on is updating it to
use the new SDK.
I don't have a timeline for you,
but it should be soon.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
This is [INAUDIBLE]
from SAP.
We had an example of device
management with a device
approved and rejected.
What are the plans for Google
regarding remote device
management?
VIC FRYZEL: Remote device
AUDIENCE: Yes.
For example, when the company
has a set of employees with
mobile devices, does Google
have plans to set up more
capabilities to manage maybe
remote device wipe or those
type of features?
VIC FRYZEL: So what we have
today is the ability to
install an application on your
device that lets you know the
state of the device remotely.
However, I don't have anything
to announce today about our
plans there in the
longer term.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
My name's Raoul.
I have two questions.
One, any update on auto
sign out or time
out for Google Apps?
Or if a user is signed in and
he is not active for 30
minutes, is there something
which we can trigger that will
sign him out of the session?
That's one.
And second question is, though
there is an audit trail which
you have started on Google
Docs, does it cover the
external files also
which we upload?
VIC FRYZEL: The external
files that you upload?
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
VIC FRYZEL: Both of your
questions I think I have a
solution to, but they're a
little bit more advanced.
Come find me afterward,
and I'd be
happy to walk you through.
AUDIENCE: Sure.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
I'm Jeff Williams from the
University of Minnesota.
At the University of Minnesota,
we have five
different domains that are each
with a different account
and they're not merged
together.
Is there any way that we could
leave the data in place but
have you update the metadata to
consolidate the domains so
that we have a single human
domain instead of having five
separate domains?
VIC FRYZEL: A single domain
instead of five separate.
So you want to merge
the domains
without merging the domains?
AUDIENCE: We want to merge them,
but we don't want to
copy all of the data that's in
there back to our servers and
lose fidelity, and then copy it
back to your servers again.
Because why?
You've got all of the documents
for all of the
different campuses, so if we
could log in as admin on the
source and the destination
domain, we might be able to
migrate the users over by just
updating on your side the
metadata that describes the
access permissions that they
have to the various pieces.
VIC FRYZEL: That's a really
good feature request.
Come find me afterward, and
I'd like to take some
requirements about that, and
then I could make sure that
that lands.
AUDIENCE: Frank LoCascio,
Esource Capital,
a Google Apps reseller.
On the APIs, is there going to
be work done on the APIs that
go after the data in the
reseller console?
VIC FRYZEL: Are there
any APIs that what?
AUDIENCE: Go after the data
in the reseller console.
VIC FRYZEL: We do have a
set of APIs for this.
Come find me afterward,
and I can point you
in the right direction.
AUDIENCE: OK, and a little bit
different than APIs, another
quick question.
Will there ever be the ability
to change the primary domain?
VIC FRYZEL: Change the
primary domain?
I don't think so.
AUDIENCE: We have companies
changing
their names, and it's--
VIC FRYZEL: Yeah, freaking
companies, man.
[LAUGHTER]
VIC FRYZEL: Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hi there.
I'm Chris.
I'm with June Star.
I support maybe 12, 15 companies
in Google Apps, and
depending on when they were
deployed, I have to juggle two
different admin consoles, resort
to GAM to get a lot of
stuff done that I can't
get done through
various ones of those.
And keeping track of who's on
where and who knows what is a
bit of a hassle.
Is this going to supplant all
of that juggling, or?
VIC FRYZEL: It's going to
definitely make a lot better.
Do you develop your
own applications?
AUDIENCE: As little as I
can, but I do have to
do some of it sometimes.
VIC FRYZEL: Two things
I would say.
One is that we're working on
making the admin panel just
more robust.
I'm sure there are certain edge
cases that you're having
trouble telling your users to
do, and that's where your
application comes into play.
I'm not sure specifically
in your case what
those edge cases are.
I'd be happy to discuss them
on a one by one basis.
But we're working on making
the admin panel just more
robust so that you can do
more of these things.
The other thing I would say is
that as we're working to hit
feature parity between the Admin
SDK and the Admin UI,
everything that you can do in
the UI, you'll be able to do
in the SDK.
So in those cases in which
you're sending a user just to
the admin panel to do one
thing and then to your
software to do something else,
they could eventually have one
destination.
It's either going to be
in the admin panel
itself or in your software.
So come find me afterward.
I'd be happy to talk about
your specific edge cases.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
VIC FRYZEL: Thanks.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Miguel from the [INAUDIBLE]
company.
Does this Admin SDK
plan to have PKI
management at one point?
VIC FRYZEL: I didn't hear
the last part, sorry.
AUDIENCE: PKI.
VIC FRYZEL: Can you--
AUDIENCE: PKI, certificate
management.
VIC FRYZEL: Sorry.
I totally did not get
your abbreviation.
Public Key Management?
AUDIENCE: Yes.
VIC FRYZEL: I don't
think that we have
that in the near future.
I would say that that's a really
good feature request.
The entire product team for the
Admin SDK is in this room,
so they're hearing everything
that you say.
[LAUGHTER]
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
VIC FRYZEL: Hey.
AUDIENCE: So I wanted to plus
one Charlie's request for the
push notifications and the
change feed for the--
VIC FRYZEL: Absolutely.
That's definitely
in the pipeline.
AUDIENCE: And also, the
[? three LO ?], understanding
what's been authorized by
someone within the domain.
VIC FRYZEL: Understanding what's
been authorized by
somebody in the domain?
AUDIENCE: Someone approves
certain requests in the
marketplace, someone within your
domain, so just to know
what has been approved by which
users within the domain.
VIC FRYZEL: Got it.
That's something we
can help you with.
AUDIENCE: Today?
VIC FRYZEL: You can view that
data today, but you can't
programmatically access
it in the SDK today.
AUDIENCE: OK.
Lastly, Charlie was also talking
about the quotas.
So I understand the per day
quota, but for us, I think the
bigger bottleneck, especially
when you're trying to run in
parallel, is the per second
quota, the server limits.
So is that--
VIC FRYZEL: We can help
you out there.
Worst case, we just
multiply your per
second quota by 80,000.
But I think we can help
you out there.
I don't know if we have a
specific per second quota set.
I'm sure we do.
No?
No.
So come find me afterward and
we can talk about how to get
your-- like I understand
that case.
Like you migrate a university
and while migrating that
university, you're making
constant requests in one day.
And you're trying to finish your
migration in less than a
week or something, right?
That's what you're
talking about?
So I understand that in that
week, your QPS is going to be
through the roof.
And then next week, you
go on vacation.
You've been paid, right?
And so we can set a very, very
high queries per day limit,
and that would still suffice.
And since there's no queries per
second limit, I think you
would be OK.
The other thing you could do
to make that even faster is
just set up concurrent
requests.
So if you thread this stuff
out, you can actually send
your QPS up very, very high
and still get a high
throughput rate for migrating
accounts or whatever.
AUDIENCE: So there's
no per second rate?
VIC FRYZEL: No.
Hold on.
I misspoke.
There is one, I just don't
know what it is off
the top of my head.
[LAUGHTER]
VIC FRYZEL: Sorry, man.
Hey.
AUDIENCE: Hey.
Jeff Williams from
the U of M again.
So you might not be the right
person, but I'm going to ask
anyway, just in case.
When we rename a user with the
API, sometimes the user's
rename doesn't go through
very quickly.
They don't get an alias or
nickname, because we've got
many domains that are there.
So they can't get mail for
potentially a day.
Most of the time,
it's not a day.
it's right away.
But then sometimes when it's
not, then apparently there's
some process that Google does
to catch up on the ones that
didn't make it successfully.
And then there's sometimes ones
that don't make it from
the first and the second
layer of that process.
And we've had tickets with
Google about it, and every
time, it's all happy and good
until we get to the third or
fourth level, and then it's
like, oh yeah, well, sorry.
VIC FRYZEL: So forgive me.
That is Google's problem,
and it's something
we're working on.
I'm sorry that you had
to endure that.
I realize that's a bad
experience, and it's something
that we really care about
and are fixing.
I'm familiar with that specific
issue, and it's
something that we've been
working on for a while.
It's a very complicated
problem on our end.
A lot of people don't quite
understand this, but
essentially when you create a
user at Google, that touches
more than 1,000 machines
instantly within
a matter of a minute.
And so keeping those machines
in sync can
sometimes be tricky.
So feel free to come find me
afterward or find any of the
team here, and I'd be happy to
help you address that as soon
as possible.
Thanks.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Just had a question about the
Google+ Profiles API versus
the Google Profiles API.
Where it does seem that, if
you have a Google+ profile
that is locked for some reason
because you've contravened a
naming convention, then the user
in the Google Profiles
API is not returned, which
doesn't seem to be documented.
Is that just the
documentation?
VIC FRYZEL: I think that is
a documentation error.
I can help you get that fixed.
Sorry about that.
Hi.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
So there have been a couple
questions about
quotas and the like.
And one of the reasons that's
been an issue for--
hasn't really been an issue
for us, but it could be a
potential issue is that the
result set size when trying to
get user information from the
Provisioning API previously
has only been 100 results
per query.
Is that going to change
with this API?
VIC FRYZEL: I think
that's changing.
It's 500 now.
AUDIENCE: 500?
Excellent.
Thanks.
VIC FRYZEL: Hey again.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Do we have an Active Directory
equivalent coming out soon?
VIC FRYZEL: Forgive me,
I didn't hear you.
AUDIENCE: Active Directory
equivalent coming out soon for
Google Apps?
VIC FRYZEL: I don't have
anything to announce today.
AUDIENCE: Active Directory
for Exchange.
There is an Active Directory
for Exchange,
so similar to that.
VIC FRYZEL: I'm familiar, but
I don't have anything to
announce today.
Sorry.
Other questions?
I think I told half of you in
the room to come find me
afterward, so it might
take a while.
But make sure that you come to
our Office Hours, which are on
the third floor.
A whole bunch of us
are going to be
there answering questions.
And then make sure to attend the
rest of the apps sessions
throughout the rest
of the day.
There's a lot of interesting
content.
Thank you very much.
[APPLAUSE]